la caserne lambert
durant la première moitié du 19e siècle
la réunion est l'unique base militaire
de la france dans l'océan indien
l'état y installe plusieurs régiments
pour lesquelles il construit les
casernes dont celle de l'infanterie de
marine dans la plaine de la redoute à
saint-denis
dessiné par le directeur du génie
militaire rouge elle est inaugurée en
au terme de trois années de travaux cet
imposant édifice en us destinés à loger
huit compagnies mesure 207 mètres de
long sur 18 mètres de profondeur cl 21
mètres sur 14 mètres 50
son entrée est marquée par une grille en
fonte de fer reliant deux pavillons à
toiture terrasse une impression générale
de grandeur et d'élégance se dégage de
cet édifice sa façade nord et
d'inspiration néoclassique les piliers
soutenant les argons plein cintre du
rez-de-chaussée et les colonnes
d'autosport au premier étage en faire un
rythme aux galeries qui précède le corps
de bâtiment
l'intérieur a subi d'importantes
modifications seule la cage d'escalier
centrale présente encore les colonnes en
fonte soutenant le plancher du premier
étage situé non loin de là l'ancienne
caserne d'artillerie de marine date de
la même époque
ces deux édifices militaire construit
sur le littoral était jusqu'au début du
20e siècle
les premiers bâtiments que découvrez les
voyageurs accostant à saint-denis
patrimoine militaire d'exception
ils sont l'un et l'autre protégé au
titre des monuments historiques depuis